that is not how we are going to talk to  one another all right no I will not be  that guy  you cannot put me in that category right  the biological father I spend every  other week with and I make polite  conversation you know well he drives me  places and buys me [ __ ] no talk to me  Samantha how was your week I don't know  what dad it was kind of tough Billy and  Ellen broke up and Ellen's kind of mad  at me because she saw me talking to  Billy in the cafeteria and you remember  that sculpture I was working on well it  was a unicorn and the horn broke off so  now it's a zebra okay but I still think  I'm gonna get an egg right Mason how was  your week well dad you know I was gonna  tough Joe he's kind of a jerk  actually he stole some cigarettes from  his mom he wanted me to smoke him but I  said no cuz I knew what a hard time you  had quittin smoking dad